Kimura-kun,
you have a lot, please give up your hair
Oh, you can stay in a place like this My boyfriend and I don't like cold places, so we dance and
sleep  The notebook is equipped with an ear that can be erected from 2 kilometers away and a
light amplification function that can see a
little light, and I also made a giant version with a total length of 18 meters
.
All living things run on electricity in the pizza area
. I put an organ around my nose that senses electricity.
Like, flowers are blooming in the space on the left and right of Wada
.
I went out to eat but they didn't make me dance and eat It's
dangerous and I can't get close.
Hmmm
[music]
I see, if you hoist Tiglasan up in the sky
Oh, that
's right
[Applause]